conséquence d'un accident de travail
christine a dû suivre une reconversion
professionnelle il y a huit ans
souffrant d'un handicap au dos
aujourd'hui elle travaille ici comme
téléconseillère elle a pu bénéficier
d'un aménagement de son poste de travail
je me suis très vite aperçu que je
n'étais pas à l'aise sur ma chaise
j'avais souvent mal au dos donc je suis
allé voir la mare responsable de des
travailleurs handicapés
et puis elle m'a dit les démarches pour
justement arriver à avoir
parmi les 180 salariés du site onze sont
des travailleurs en situation de
handicap dans cette entreprise leur
bien-être est pris très au sérieux des
temps des changes sont régulièrement
organisés qu'on rôle c'est de les
accompagner d'être à leur écoute et de
mettre en place des aménagements de
poste lorsque c'est nécessaire
après c'est des échanges réguliers aussi
avec eux dans le quotidien pouvoir s'il
n'y a pas des choses à améliorer parce
que le handicap aussi peu évolué et donc
l'aménagement peut à un moment donné ne
plus correspondre et du coup le modifier
cependant le handicap reste aujourd'hui
un frein à l'emploi
en cause notamment les difficultés
économiques rencontrées par les
entreprises
c'est plus difficile effectivement mais
aussi parce que le contexte économique
est compliqué donc forcément quand vous
avez un handicap
vous êtes deux fois plus discriminés et
surtout quand on sait que la population
travailleur handicapé cessation eux
c'est surtout public âgé à bas niveaux
de qualification donc entre guillemets
on a
une double peine selon un dernier
recensement réalisé en août
près de 3000 personnes en situation de
handicap
figurent parmi les inscrits à pôle
emploi dans le département de l'yonne